some new improvements are now open at  mulaskey family park that is over on the  east side of the valley near Twain and  Maryland Parkway the newest addition to  the park includes a Youth Soccer Park a  new law and watering system an offense  that wraps around the park those  involved in revamping the park say it  was extremely important to have  community input and surveyed literally  we went to departments we went to the  school which of the condos that are over  here what do you want  keep the dog park that was especially  important to people but with the kids  both many of them go to or and Peterson  and so though they have their soccer  fields over there there's nothing in  this little immediate area  the mulaskey family parks newest  additions are dedicated to influential  Las Vegas developer or Wynn mulaskey who  passed away last week